all right protests over the police
shooting death of a black man inside his
own apartment in Dallas screw tense
overnight
a Dallas Morning News journalists
captured an officer firing what appeared
to be a pepper ball gun into the crowd
[Applause]
more than a hundred people gathered to
demand justice for Botham John the 26
year old was shot last week by off-duty
police officer
amber Geiger Omar Villafranca is at the
Dallas apartment complex where it all
happened
Omar good morning Nora good morning
Geiger is charged with manslaughter
after what happened at this apartment
complex but demonstrators say that is
not enough her case now heads to a grand
jury where those charges could be bumped
up to murder dozens of demonstrators
gathered outside Dallas Police
Headquarters Monday evening demanding
justice for both am john dallas county
district attorney faith johnson we will
make certain that justice is done in
this case according to an arrest warrant
Geiger told investigators that she went
to what she thought was her third-floor
apartment instead she went to John's
fourth floor apartment directly above
hers Geiger says her door was ajar and
she saw a large silhouette inside after
giving verbal commands that were ignored
she fired her handgun twice
striking both them once in the torso it
wasn't until Geiger turned on the lights
and called 911 she was at the wrong
apartment
attorneys for John's family say two
witnesses told them details that
contradict Geiger's account they heard
knocking down the hallway followed by a
woman's voice that they believed to be
officer Geiger saying let me in let me
in the family's attorneys say one of the
witnesses then heard gunshots followed
by a man's voice what we believe to be
the last words of both them John which
was oh my god why did she do that
Alison Sean wants to know what happened
to her son I'm not satisfied that
all the answers there's really no reason
why a mother should have to wait until
the conclusion of an investigation to
know what happened to our child the
Texas Rangers are leading this
investigation while the Shawn family is
planning for a very large funeral on
Thursday Gayle all right thank you very
much Omar a lot of questions remaining
there